[Musique]
le 5 cristobal ce restaurant privé du
centre de la havane avait déjà bonne
réputation
son chef et propriétaire carlos aussi le
21 mars 2016
le saint christ au bal est devenu le
restaurant d'obama quel sera le sort
[Musique]
même pas une heure de préavis
la surprise totale c'est le seul endroit
à cuba où barack obama a eu un repas de
famille privée avec son épouse et ses
deux filles et trois cents à la guy la
bossa nova et la audriaz la pause à la
fois ils ont goûté à toutes nos
spécialités dit carlos qui a été très
impressionné par le président américain
moi c'est pas déboiser mbba des gones
après cela est faux les cubains ont
adoré barack obama il apportait un
espoir nouveau dans une relation
nouvelle plus de 22 accords ont été
signés un record même les dirigeants
cubains ont craqué mais ces mêmes
dirigeants vite déchanté obama est parti
mais le blocus est restée la base légale
de guantanamo aussi la subversion
continue avec tv martí la domination
demeure ailier ramires est spécialisé
dans les relations cuba et à zune pass
on est importante
c'était des pas importants mais il
aurait vraiment pu transformer le blocus
en une coquille vide un hangar caramba
c'est aux romands obama aurait-il pu
aurait-il dû faire plus
quatre autres années de démocrates au
pouvoir auraient-elles abouti à de
vraies relations normales on en débattra
à l'infini puis c'est le coup de
tonnerre et les sanctions sont tombées
défense de faire affaire avec les
entreprises cubaines dirigé par l'armée
c'est une grande partie du secteur
touristique et restrictions pour les
voyageurs américains à cuba
ça a eu son effet le nombre des
visiteurs est considérablement diminué
depuis quand
depuis depuis peu aux autres mois d'août
pourquoi carlos à ce gala est un ancien
diplomate cubain donne des conférences
aux visiteurs américains selon la loi
ils ne peuvent pas faire du simple
tourisme à la plage au soleil comme tout
le monde ils doivent avoir un programme
culturel religieux ou sportifs
il ya moins de
oui
à cause d'eux à cause du gouffre
maintenant mais aussi avec l'embassy qui
avait des problèmes
elle parle des soi disant attaque
acoustique à l'ambassade américaine
c'est surtout ça qui décourage les
visiteurs américains il ya un impact
psychologique
il faut pas voyager à quoi dangereux
parce que 24 diplomates américains ont
été victimes de troubles auditifs et
cérébraux huit canadiens aussi
le mystère demeure les cubains ont fait
enquête le fbi a eu aussi et la
gendarmerie royale canadienne
on n'a rien trouvé mais le président
américain continue d'accuser les cubains
il a expulsé des diplomates cubains et
rappeler le tiers du personnel de son
ambassade crise diplomatique sérieuse
elle revient de nom de leur retard ni où
aller serrer nos politiques s'arrêtent
aux chercheurs et aux chaleurs comme au
prétexte ou par retrait de la relation
bilatérale et à l'ipod cas de la
confrontation
jerez la rega a marre au t71 retour à la
rhétorique hostile des années 60 de la
guerre froide
à l'époque mais certains ici trouvent
que donald trump ja plus fort qu'il ne
mord on s'attendait au pire on a cru
qu'il allait changer tout ce qu obama
avait fait non il en a changé très peu
[Musique]
le tourisme n'est pas trop affecté les
bateaux de croisière même américains
sont de plus en plus nombreux trump n'a
pas touché non plus aux précieux envois
d'argent des exilés de floride
la principale source de deux villes de
l'île cela aurait été catastrophique les
stores garcia se risque même à prédire
que 30 pourrait améliorer les relations
dans l'intérêt de ses partisans ce n'est
pas noir ou blanc
il y a des gens dans l'administration
trolls qui veulent faire des affaires
avec cuba l'appart à erik haula dans le
secteur agricole surtout son secrétaire
l'agriculture c'est sony piriou perdre
du quai qu'est-ce qu'ils vont perdre ue
du poulet et cuba qu'est ce qu'ils
achètent du poulet pouilles
en attendant une hypothétique éclaircies
les cubains vont faire ce qu'ils ont
l'habitude de faire depuis si longtemps
en durée et attendre que ça passe mais
je passe qui est éventuellement nous
retournerons à les processus qui obama
commençait allemand mais ça peut prendre
après ça peut prendre au moins
et si jamais donald trump ce risque est
à son tour à la havane c'est de savoir
si oui carlos n'hésiterait pas l'inviter
[Musique]